- I did a local show here
on Channel 11, on Fox 11,
all through the pandemic.
We were doing updates every
day on what was going on.
And we had somebody from
the school board come in,
weekend when they decided
they were gonna
close the schools.
And I was like, "How did
you arrive at this decision?
Who were the physicians
that advise you,
who were the?"
"We just decided to do it."
It's like, why, how long,
what are the consequences?
How are you,
you should see now the data,
there's this group called Gaggle
that documents the
data of adverse events
from the use of screens,
in terms of sexting,
access to porn, violent and
suicidal sort of musing online.
It's like up 400% and
it's up in elementary age
as well as middle-school.
(upbeat pensive music)
- All right, I am in
studio with a live,
a real live human being
according to the
paperwork, Dr. Drew Pinsky.
It is good to see
you, my friend.
- It is good to see you and to
be fair, I insisted on this.
I did, you were like,
"No, we'll do it by Zoom."
I'm like, "No, I don't
wanna do it by Zoom anymore,
I'm tired of this."
I've seen this great studio.
I wanna be in it with
you, I wanna see you.
- It's good to see you.
We are less than six feet apart,
so we're risking
everything right now.
- You're risking everything,
I'm as immune as
I can possibly be.
- You got COVID like 18 times.
- I've had COVID, I've
had the injection,
I've had the vaccine, I'm good.
And I do something
that no one does,
I'm following a very
sophisticated antibody screen
with my neutralizing antibodies
and my B cell function.
So I can tell you
categorically, if I get COVID,
it'd be a reportable.
- Do you feel like your life's
work has led to this moment?
And there are people-
- No I don't,
I never expected any of this,
nor do I really
welcome it, to be fair,
but I will, I took the Johnson
& Johnson vaccine myself
and I had a nasty reaction
to it, really bad,
I woke up with a
sudden black eye,
which we call it
a raccoon's eye,
which is the presenting symptom
of transverse sinus thrombosis,
which is the
dreaded complication
of the Johnson &
Johnson vaccine.
I'm looking in the mirror
going, "Oh, God damn it,
am I gonna have a transverse
sinus thrombosis and nothing?
- And nothing.
- So if I take another one,
we'll see.
- And so, did you choose
the Johnson & Johnson
one intentionally?
- I did, I did, I sort of
picked it early for two reasons.
One, I react horribly to
viruses, horribly to vaccines.
So I kind of just
wanted one vaccine,
silly me now I need another.
But I was hoping just
to get by with one,
also, I liked the idea
of a sort of an old
fashioned platform
and nothing against Moderna,
I might even take the Moderna
now, or the mRNA vaccines,
but I just thought, "Eh,
I react to everything,
better I use something
old-fashioned."
- So before we get to the book,
which I'm holding in my hand,
so I'll put it
down for a moment.
Let's just do the COVID stuff.
- Let's do the COVID
stuff, let's get it.
- And just kind of
get it out of the way,
- Push to the side.
- So all right,
you've got antibodies,
you did Johnson & Johnson
You don't have a
problem with mRNA.
Is there anything that people
should know about the mRNA
we're hearing so much
conflicting stuff.
And I had Dr. Brian Keating
on my show last week,
talking about that people just
don't trust experts anymore.
And in many cases, it's
the experts' fault, so-
- Right, but particularly
the CDC's fault.
I mean, and the government,
anybody associated with
Public Health or CDC
has created vaccine
hesitancy, they've created it.
They've done everything wrong.
They should have been from
the beginning, wide open.
Here's our thinking,
here's our concerns.
Here's the debate we
have behind closed,
all that is how you get people
who are resistant to loosen
up and come on board.
You treat them like
intelligent people
who need to be reasoned with,
and you give them
all the information.
You don't say you
can't handle the truth.
You can't handle the truth,
I'd become resistant.
What's bizarre to me is
we learned how to do this
during the HIV epidemic.
I don't know if I
ever told you this.
I got involved in
radio because in 1983,
one Anthony Fauci, who
was my hero at the time,
was telling us young physicians
that we had to get out there
and educate and change behavior
because we couldn't get
people to stop having sex
and passing this virus.
And I thought, oh, and I
took it very seriously.
And we learned across
that, that pandemic
with a 100% fatality rate,
it was the darkest
of darkest hours.
We learned that the way
you changed behaviors
is with narratives
and information
and showing the consequences
of people's choices
a little humor, a little music,
that's how you change behavior.
Not me in a box, pointing
my finger at somebody
it's the opposite.
- Right, so I've heard you talk
about your experience
with Fauci then.
And you've been, I think
very fair to Fauci,
I would say almost
overly fair, like to me-
- I'm been overly fair
because I've been through five
pandemics with him, right?
He was really my man during
HIV, MERS, SARS-1, H1N1,
H1N1 was a terrible pandemic,
you don't even
know what happened,
- Yeah, nobody really knows.
- That's what I kept saying
during the outbreak
of this one.
- Yeah.
- I was like, that was bad
and you're worrying
about this one.
Like, why didn't we
have a moderate reaction
to that one, at least,
why this reaction, anyway.
But, so I figured he had
been adulterated by the,
what everyone get
adulterated with,
which is the
tribalism of our time.
And I thought he would
revert to the mean,
I thought his overall
function has always been like,
his judgment has been awesome.
And I would see, I assume,
I still to this day,
believe we'll see a
reversion to the mean,
in terms of him looking okay.
However, he finally did
something that upset me,
which was, I don't know
if you remember him
in front of Congress
multiple times,
whenever they would ask him
about the gain-of-function,
or funding.
- Yeah we've covered it, yeah.
- He would just be
like, I'm confused,
what are you talking
about, I have nothing,
two days ago, he goes,
"Well, we did fund
change viral function,
we did, not this, but we
were changing viruses."
- Right, right that was the
word, he said, "Change of."
- Why didn't you tell
us, that's what we were,
that's how you create
vaccine hesitancy.
Now it's like, "Okay,
I can't trust you."
You knew what we were asking,
answer the damn question,
be open about this,
trust the American people
to be able to digest
what you're telling them
and give them a recommendation
and then move on.
- So do you think in essence
he lied under oath to Rand Paul?
- I don't really have
an opinion about that,
so much as to say-
- 'Cause change of seems to be
the word that he's confusing-
- You can't do that right now,
you gotta be open and honest.
You cannot obfuscate,
this is dissembling.
You cannot, whether it's lying
or worthy of sort of
further investigation,
I have no opinion.
It's dissembling,
it's obfuscating.
You can't be that way now,
that's how you create
vaccine hesitancy.
I've gotten to the point now
where I'm telling people,
your problem,
I've talked to lots of
vaccine hesitant people,
your problem is you
don't know who to trust,
so here's what I want you to do.
I want you to find
if it's for the kids,
find a pediatrician, for
its you find an internist
that you trust and you
sit down with that person
and you two make
that medical decision
the way we're supposed to make
all fucking medical decisions.
The fact that anybody
has an opinion
about what a doctor
does with his patients
is offensive and disgusting.
The fact that anybody
has an opinion
about what Joe Rogan's
doctor does with him,
that's disgusting.
Now other physicians can
have opinions about it
and we can discuss
it professionally,
but for people in the world
to interfere with
that relationship,
that is disgusting.
And why people aren't more upset
about the adulteration
of the relationship
between doctors and
patients, I'm gobsmacked,
is the word I would say.
- Yeah, no, I can see it,
look, I know you pretty
well off camera too.
I'm pretty sure I've
never heard Dr. Drew,
or my friend Drew.
- Say that word.
- Say the F-bomb before.
- I'm upset, yeah.
- So I get it, so-
- It's not that I don't say it,
it's that I use
different words. (laughs)
- So, (laughs) so-
- You put a pretty
party on here,
I'm on my best
behavior. (laughs)
- I do all right,
but so to that end,
I mean, I assume I've heard
you talk about it a little bit.
Are you a hundred
percent against mandates
as a general rule?
- Am I a hundred-
- To what you just said.
- I mean, you want people.
- The one thing I've learned
about medicine.
- To make decisions
with their doctor.
- The one thing I've
learned about medicine,
is you never say always and
never, you just never do that.
So am I against mandates
generally, yes, absolutely.
I'm against the idea that this,
now I understand that
we need to do things
to urge populations
to do certain things.
I don't see where it's the,
look, I was in France, you
been to France recently?
It's very changed.
- I've only been
to France once, it was in 1997,
I assume it's all the same.
- I suggest
you go back there now,
because it's very interesting
what's happening there.
What's happening there,
they have same mandates
we have essentially,
they apply it very differently.
When you go to the Louvre,
you can show your EU Pass
or go over there and get a test,
if you'd like,
whatever you want.
And or you can show
us your antibodies
from your natural
immunity, rational.
That's not a, there's a mandate,
but a rational
application of a mandate.
And the really interesting thing
is the youth are
fighting like crazy.
So 18 to 28 year olds are in
the streets by the thousands.
- Yeah, you don't
see that on CNN.
- "Vive la liberte,"
is their call,
this is I've spoke to,
my French is pretty good.
I spoke to a lot of them,
'cause I was intrigued.
I'm like young people not
asking for more mask wearing?
I don't understand.
They were furious and
their position was,
look, you've educated us rightly
that this thing is not
a major risk to us.
Now you're mandating us put
something in our bodies.
We may choose to do
it and you can help us
make that decision
if you think it's so,
mandating it, no.
And it's echoes of
1790, I'm telling you,
they bring up the
same language as 1790,
they raised their fists.
- And they've got a history
of beheading over there, so.
- Well, I don't think this
is that kind of mob action.
Yeah, but that's going on here,
it's called cancel culture.
But I remember I was
talking to a woman
at the ticket counter
as I was leaving
and I thought, "Oh,
she's about 25,
I'm gonna bring this up."
And I brought it up,
started talking to her
and she got, she's this big
and she got out from
behind the counter,
and she goes, "Vive la
liberte, it's so important,
do you understand what
they're doing to us?"
And I thought,
"Wow, 25 year olds,"
this is their idea now,
as opposed to a study
that was done at Stanford,
where they looked
at the irrationality
around signaling and masks,
this researcher
went up to Stanford,
looked at Stanford
students on bicycles.
What percentage were
wearing helmets?
What percentage
were wearing masks?
- Yeah.
- 60% mask, 20% helmet.
- [Dave] Hilarious.
- This virus does not
transmit out of doors.
It does not transmit out
of doors, even the Delta,
really doesn't
transmit out of doors.
That's insane, that
is an insanity.
- Okay, so there's a lot there.
So first are you shocked,
we're here in LA.
- Yeah.
- It's beautiful out every day.
Yes, unfortunately
we are here for now.
You almost ran for
governor, by the way.
I don't know if you
wanted that to be-
- I thought, I was in the
contemplative phase, yes, yes.
- I was kind of pushing
you too, but it-
- Yes you were.
- But it didn't happen.
- That was probably
when I was here,
was as close I came to
making a serious effort.
I think I called
Governor Schwarzenegger
the next day or something,
to see what his thoughts were
and he pushed me even further,
I was surprised, I thought
he'd try to talk me out of it.
- But what stopped
you at the end?
- I needed radiation-
- For the record, 'cause I
know everyone's listening.
- For the record.
- This was also before
Larry Elder got involved.
- No, I started
talking to people
about going to what they
called the money class,
which is a shocking
thing to hear,
already my naive
brain was exploding,
but it turned out I
needed some radiation
for my prostate cancer.
So I was looking down a
few weeks of radiation
that would interrupt everything.
We were still gonna go
to France and I was like,
this is not,
something's telling me,
this is not the right
time and that was that.
And the radiation is fine.
It's is a relatively
perfunctory treatment
in the kind of
prostate cancer I have.
And it's like all cancers,
chronic illnesses that you
can live with for decades.
So, like many cancers are.
- You are a true
television professional,
because when you
have to make a point
you go to the camera
instead. (laughs)
- (laughs) When it's
an important point,
trust me, I'm here.
- Okay, so that
aside, here in LA,
when I go to the supermarket,
they still want you to put
the mask on, obviously.
To me, I'm looking at people,
it doesn't seem as if anyone
is even thinking anymore.
- No.
- They're all walking around,
they kind of, everyone has
this sort of glossed over look.
- Mission accomplished.
- They're wearing it
in the parking lot.
- Yup.
- And it's like,
we don't even talk.
There's no, why isn't
Garcetti giving a speech
every now and again,
we're thinking about
maybe taking the mask off,
like the ship has sailed.
It's like it's over.
- I know the way to manage,
another way to manage vaccine
hesitancy is with rewards.
Hey, everybody get vaccine,
if I can get to 80%,
I'm gonna get rid
of these mandates,
we're gonna open up the schools,
the kids, I mean, just the kids.
Do you understand
there's several pediatric
psychiatric associations
and hospital associations
have declared a national mental
health emergency on kids.
And somebody was asking me,
I was lecturing a teacher's
group and they're like,
"What can you do, what
can you do to help kids?"
I said, "Look, what
they need is contact.
They need you in your presence,
they need you to
be on their level,
listening and reflect,
this thing called
reflective functioning.
Where you use your face
to reflect the emotions
that you see in the children.
It's extremely,
it's what we call
building affect regulation,
it gets into the brain in
a way that words do not.
And I was thinking about what
I normally recommend for this.
And one of the teachers
goes, "But the masks."
and I thought, "Oh my God,"
I'm at a loss for words.
- What do you think
we're doing really,
to the kids at that age,
when I think of my
nieces and nephews-
- Because all we
know is the numbers,
you just look at the numbers,
suicide, depression, substance
use, it's just going crazy.
I mean like at what
the, if you're 18,
you're eight years old or
12 years old or 14 year old
and you start every
time you turn on the TV
or get on the internet, you
see your parents are in danger,
your family's
gonna be destroyed.
Of course, that late
adolescence, early childhood,
excuse me, late childhood,
early adolescence,
a very grandiose phase
where you believe
everything's gonna happen
to you, that's normal.
The way to destroy their psyche
is what we've been doing.
- So, all right, so backing
up a little bit to Fauci,
for a second, so I've
been covering this a lot
and I always try to say,
I'm not trying to impugn his
motives, but I am starting to,
I honestly am, to me,
he has bungled this
to the point of
almost ridiculousness,
like literally at
the height of it,
telling us all to wear masks,
but then emailing his friends
who were going on vacation
to say the masks you buy
at stores don't work.
And actually then the
video came out later,
him telling someone
else on PBS years ago,
that masks actually make
you touch your face more.
But then he's telling
people to double mask,
like there's been such
a series of crazy things
that it leaves someone like me,
that's fairly well-educated.
I talked to people like
you and I watch him
and I think, "The ship
has sailed with this guy."
- Public Health definitely,
whatever Public Health official
has just bungled this entirely,
again, it was astonishing,
I don't know why they
did what they did,
it doesn't make any sense.
They defied everything
we've learned
about changing
behavior in a pandemic.
and I don't know why
they did, I don't get it,
but there was something
you were saying,
oh, so here's the deal
with the mask thing, right?
So influenza, well, you
know the whole story
about where the
lockdowns came from,
from a high school
student in Albuquerque.
- Yeah, you're right,
it was something that
was never studied, right.
- It was never
meant for anything.
- It was just sort of a joke.
- Although, I saw her father
online a little while ago,
doubling down that she
saved millions of lives,
it was the right thing to do.
So he who published
the paper that said,
"Local lockdowns for influenza
is a good idea," may be.
National lockdowns for
a respiratory virus,
we have no idea,
totally different
transmission range.
- You mean the people
in rural Montana
maybe should have a
different reaction
than people living
in Midtown Manhattan?
- What, I don't understand
what you're talking about.
- Geez, you are a doctor.
- Is there a difference
between those two populations?
But so the mask with influenza,
we do recommend
you don't wear it,
because the hand is the
primary transmission unit
and so getting hands to
the away from the face
is our primary goal.
So he was applying the
principles of influenza,
thinking this was gonna
be like influenza,
I would defend him on that.
What I don't defend is the
theater around mask wearing.
What is the efficacy of masks?
Do you ever hear anybody
talking about that?
- No, we don't anymore.
- Okay and do you
have any studies about
this, do you think?
Okay, there've been
two huge studies.
One was the Danish study
and there was tremendous
excitement around this study.
We couldn't wait
to see a publisher
to find out how well
these masks work.
Suddenly everyone starts passing
on the publication, JAMA.
- Ahh, I can see
where this is going.
- It's finally published
in the "Annals of
Internal Medicine," right?
And it's published and it shows
about a 15 to 20% efficacy
of mask wearing, which
was not zero, not zero,
but not 80 and not a hundred
percent, it's 15 to 20%.
Then there was a huge study
that came out of Bangladesh,
that was highly criticized,
but not a bad study,
showed again, 15 to 20% in that
range, maybe a little less.
And that's it, that seems
to be what masks do.
People behave as
though they're 100%
and wearing them outdoors
makes zero sense,
like none, zero, but
indoors it's like,
okay, we wanna do
something, we wanna,
but to treat people like
they're some sort of,
wielding a murderous weapon
by not wearing the mask.
Again, we need to educate people
about the reality of masks,
you're better off
just distancing,
that's significantly better,
so anyways, just a
signal at this point.
- So when you talk,
when you mentioned what
happened at the Louvre,
and okay, so you
have to have a test,
or you can be
tested right there,
or they check your antibodies,
something like that.
Like that old sort of
intellectually does
make sense to me,
but where I'm at,
at this point is-
- I tell you, emotionally,
it's a lot more pleasant,
'cause they're literally
like, "What do you want?
What do you wanna do,
you take your choice."
- But I would give you something
even more emotionally
pleasant to me,
which would be if
you've been vaccinated,
go in and if you wanna
wear a mask, wear a mask-
- That's kind of the
way it is in New York.
- And no, I know it, it's
just fine in New York.
I mean, I was shocked
when I was in New York
a couple of weeks
ago, people were just-
- They just scan, they
put a wrist band on you.
- But they were barely doing it,
they were barely doing it.
- Really, oh.
- When I was there.
- You see when I went there,
it was right when it had
started and they were doing it
and they're like, "You can take
your mask off, forget that.
We'll make the staff wear
it, but you get out of it."
- But how worried are you
about the conditioning of it?
Whether you send people to
go check your antibodies,
or let me look at this.
- It's what Adam Carolla
calls crate training.
- Yes.
- We've all been
crate trained.
- Yes, that is
what I am far more
concerned about.
- You're worried about.
- The mind virus, more
than the COVID virus.
- Yes, I worry about it.
I've always been a stream
moderate, middle everything.
And I think I was a
little more liberal,
but liberal kind
of left me somehow.
- I know that feeling.
- Yeah and it makes me seem
more right, I'm not, trust me.
I mean, I've spent decades
fighting the right,
because they were the
ones not letting me talk
about HPV vaccines and
morning after contraception.
I mean, I was really
in conflict with it.
Now, it seems like it's
coming from the other side,
which is astonishing to me.
- Don't worry,
my audience gets it.
- It's very weird, it's
very weird, but we'll have,
shit, I lost my train
of thought, the-
- Well, the mind
virus, basically and
when and how this is-
- So, Adam was just saying how
we've all been crate trained
and that it's complete now,
the crate training is complete
and they don't have to worry
about, I'm generally mystified.
I know what I was gonna
say, I'm generally mystified
by people that want
orders from without
and the people that want
to issue those orders.
That's mysterious to me.
I don't understand
why Gavin Newsom
would feel okay about this.
I talked to a governor, a
friend of mine in another state
who called me and said,
"They want me to put a mask
mandate, that's not my job.
I don't tell people, I
don't, that's not government,
that's not what I
should be doing."
He was eventually
persuaded to do it,
'cause the pressure got so high.
I don't, and now I lost
my train of thought again,
this is what COVID did to me.
- Did COVID?
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah,
it gave me some weird stuff.
- Huh.
- And this is why
I have more train
of thought trouble
than aging alone
used to give me.
- Interesting, interesting.
- Now it's like it
interferes with my-
- Well, we're talking about
the crate training aspect of it
and that basically everyone
is just bowing to
demands of people-
- Yeah.
- Who oddly
want to demand things.
- So, this is the other thing
I was gonna say,
which is, one thing
that I have changed on,
even though I was
staying in the middle
and I'm still the same
ideas I've always had,
I never was aware, aware of
how much I valued freedom
and how much it needed
to be protected.
I'd heard about that,
I'd laughed about that,
when military people
talked about it,
I literally made fun of it.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- And all of a sudden that has
become a vivid reality to me
that freedom is
something to be cherished
and to be defended and we
better pay attention to that
and the masking is
the opposite of that.
Now I'm not saying
you shouldn't mask.
I'm saying you should not
be taken by the mind virus,
if you do mask, you
should be doing it,
because you've decided
to make a difference
for that 15% effect and
you're doing the best you can,
not because somebody
told you to do it.
Right, see the difference.
- Right, so of course,
so the other part then,
I would say the next
extension of that
is the thing that
I'm worried about,
which is that we
are now othering.
I don't think we
sitting in this room,
but mainstream is
now othering people
who are making medical
choices for themselves
to the point where
they're basically
saying you're diseased,
which by the way, if you
haven't been vaccinated,
it doesn't mean you have COVID,
but you're diseased
and you're gonna
potentially come kill me,
which is an odd anti-vax
statement by the way,
if you believe
the vaccines work,
but can you just
talk a little bit
about the psychology about that?
Because one thing
that's popped up now
is like, you could sort of see
how the Nazis did
horrible things now.
When you other
people in a society.
- Yes, well, I need to, let
me actually write stuff down
as I'm talking to you.
- Yeah, we can make that happen.
- Can I get a piece of paper.
- We'll get something.
- What's happening is I'm
having so many thoughts at once.
- Yeah, (laughs) we
can make that happen.
- So there's one form of
othering that I spotted early,
that I knew was
gonna be a problem
and that was what they
were doing in New York.
When you have to have a
vaccine to go to a restaurant
to go anywhere essentially.
And in New York City,
there was a high degree
of vaccine hesitancy
in African-Americans and
I thought, what is this?
You're creating an out-group
based on the historical
treatment of a population
due to their race.
There's a very compelling
reason Black people, Black folk,
have distrust of
the medical system.
They were mishandled
throughout much of history.
God knows on the mental health
side, it's even been worse.
And I'm not just talking
about the Tuskegee Experiment.
I'm talking generally medicine,
just look at how we treated
the cocaine pandemic,
we treated that as a criminal
problem, thank God I did not.
I treated lots of
cocaine addicts
and I treated them as
people with an illness,
the way we did with
the opiate epidemic.
Point being that you
create an out-group
based on a historical
treatment of a population
due to their skin color and
now you're telling them,
because of that, you're out.
That is that well, that's as
racist as you can possibly be.
And it's creating an out-group.
So there's now we created
an out-group there.
Out-group and the
unvaccinated who gets sick, ,
they shouldn't get
access to treatment,
have you seen that talk?
- No, this is extraordinary now.
- That means that anybody
who makes a bad decision
that has an impact on
their medical condition
should be prevented from
accessing medical care.
What happens to my patients?
The heroin addicts,
the alcoholics,
they're all making bad choices
all the time, just die.
No access for you.
In fact, you'd have to
close emergency rooms.
'Cause the emerge are
filled with people
who are doing stupid shit.
That's mostly what's going
on, people are in accidents,
people using drugs, people
not taking their meds,
people, I mean, it's
mostly what it is.
And so all those
people no longer get
access to medical care
is that we're saying?
- It's also against
the Hippocratic Oath,
isn't that the number one thing?
- I'm gonna talk to
Arthur Caplan on Monday,
on my streaming show
and this is what I
wanna get into with him.
He's a human medical ethicist,
I think he's at Cornell.
And he took the position that
it was okay not to treat,
I believe that's
what he concluded.
It was okay for doctors not
to treat unvaccinated people,
which I'm like, I
just can't even-
- Well, the premise
being that this is such
an extraordinary moment.
- Look.
- Something to that effect.
- I was presented with,
I was presented with treating,
there was a horrible,
this is way up in
the late eighties,
we had a horrible shootout,
it was an Asian gang
in a part of, sort of,
San Marino, Monterey
Park and it really,
an ambush on a group of officers
and these guys were animals
and some of them were
shot and came to our ER.
I ethically had to treat,
I didn't want to.
- Of course, of course.
- I thought about not doing it.
It was my obligation
to treat those guys
and I thought they
should, they deserved,
I had all kinds of horrible
thoughts about them,
but I treated
them, I did my job.
And the fact that we turn
away from that is bizarre.
So we have based on
race, based on behavior,
which is how you get
bad medical outcomes.
And then it's
hardening them, right?
It's making them into a tribe
and it's hardening
their resistance,
by telling them they're
dumb and ignorant
and don't know
what they're doing.
All of them, I talked,
well, I don't know,
I talked to lots of them and
it's always the same story,
which is, I don't
know who to trust,
I don't know where to
get good information.
And I've been, like I told you,
I've been telling them to
get together with a doctor.
Now, get together
with your doctor,
someone you trust and make
that decision together,
the way medicine has
always been practiced.
- And by the way, I will
give you credit here,
where it's due,
which is that you were
one of the first people
out of the gate
probably a month in,
when everybody was just
going along with groupthink,
lock everything down,
shut everybody down,
just go out and you
were one of the,
do you know how many weeks
that was in, basically?
- It was immediate,
right when the,
well, it was actually
during the Wuhan outbreak,
we didn't, it'd barely
gotten to Italy yet.
I was saying, "Stop using
the word staggering, stop it,
it's not staggering, there's
gonna be big numbers,
what are you gonna call
that, incomprehensible?"
Like, staggering.
- So this was probably like
February of 2020, right?
- It was February,
it was February,
I was in Denver on a
TV show, and I said,
"Just the press
needs to shut up,
everything they're doing is
gonna create more problem.
Panic does not help
things, listen to the CDC."
I then I was saying,
"Listen to the CDC,
listen to Dr. Fauci.
They're the people
whose job it is
to get us through this stuff."
And then Trump
derangement took off.
It was like the "New York
Times" editorial board
had a opinion about medical
management of a pandemic.
They should, they should
be, they should be,
that to me, that's
almost a criminal action
to try to interfere
with the operation
of a medical decision-making
process with an organization,
multiple organizations, they
scared everybody to death
where my profession froze and
it was astonishing to see,
it was astonishing, I made
a huge mistake in there,
by in the middle too, I
was comparing it to H1N1,
see, it's a mistake to compare
one pandemic from another.
But I was just trying
to get everyone
just to kind of put it
in context and calm down
and let's make some
good decisions.
Think how different
this would have been,
if somebody had said,
"This is gonna be awful,
we're gonna get through this."
Medical system here
in the United States
is the best in the
world, we'll flex up,
it'll be a challenge, but
we will get enough beds,
we'll have enough ICU,
we'll get more ventilators.
And we will find a way to a
vaccine and some treatments,
it's what we do best,
so let's get this.
Now for a couple of weeks
while we figure things out.
- It's kind of what
Trump said, isn't it?
It's kind of what Trump said.
- It was impossible to tell
what was coming out
of there at that time.
- I don't know why I'm
whispering to you, but-
- Yeah, well, there was a lot
of different stuff coming out,
but in the meantime,
lock it down
while we figure out
what's going on.
See if we're right and see
if this is really something
that we can handle this way.
And then let's keep
the kids in school,
like so many
countries are doing.
I mean, let's minimize
the collateral damage
from this thing
instead of maximizing
the collateral damage.
- In retrospect, do
you think it's nuts?
Like if I had a time machine,
I had a DeLorean and
I'm going back in time.
- (laughs) Had to be a DeLorean.
- It has to be a DeLorean,
it's not a phone booth,
it's a DeLorean,
I'm back in time.
To me it seems that we should
not have locked down anything,
we should have said to people
wear masks, if you
wanna wear masks,
life is gonna continue,
we're gonna work on a vaccine
and we're just gonna
do the best we can.
And to me, no matter
what the result,
even if the death uptake
had been a bit more
than it is right now,
we would be much better off,
because now the cascading
problems throughout society,
you've mentioned between work
and health and mental health
and everything else.
- Oh it's unbelievable.
- Weight, I mean, the amount
of weight people have gained,
there's all sorts of things.
- And to be fair, some
people have been through this
and benefited.
I talked to a woman, 90
year old woman this morning,
who said, "This thing has
been a blessing for me,
because I could stay home
and do these things."
I thought, "Okay, I can
accept that it's not all bad."
But and I have many friends,
smart friends who say,
when I say things
like you just said,
they go, "We needed to lock
down, we needed to figure out,
we really didn't know
what's going on."
I go, "Okay, for awhile,"
but to have done it with
no end point, with no goal.
I remember I was,
I did a local show here
on Channel 11, on Fox 11,
all through the pandemic, we
were doing updates every day
on what was going on.
And we had somebody from
the school board come in,
weekend when they decided
they were gonna
close the schools.
And I was like, "How did
you arrive at this decision?
Who were the physicians
that advise you?
Who were the,"
"We just decided to do it."
It's like, why, how long,
what are the consequences?
How are you?
You should see now the data,
there's this group
called Gaggle,
that documents the
data of adverse events
from the use of screens,
in terms of sexting,
access to porn, violent and
suicidal sort of musing online.
It's like up 400% and
it's up in elementary age,
as well as middle
school and high school.
- 'Cause we
literally forced them
to have their only
interactions on these screens.
- Correct and did
nothing to protect them
from all the
consequences of screens,
that we know the screen, we're
gonna look at the screens
the way we look at
tobacco, in 20 years,
there's no doubt in my mind,
but to think, think about it.
We gave kids cartons
of cigarettes,
and said this make it
feel better, here you go,
this will help you
with your education.
- And so instead
we said to them,
"You're not going to school,"
put a computer in their room.
They have access to
God knows what all day
on top of just the general-
- And on top of the
isolation, the fear,
the lack of socialization,
the lack of
developmental milestones,
and just lack of
academic progress
and just throw our hands up.
Well, what are you gonna do?
- Is there a psychological
term for that feeling
that that first two weeks
when lockdowns were starting,
where there was almost
this odd excitement?
Like not joy, I would say,
but everyone just felt like,
"Oh, there's something going on.
It's like a little bit
out of our mundane lives."
- I didn't have that.
- I remember I was on Fox
and I brought my dog
on, 'cause I was home
and they love my dog is
on Fox, it's so great,
I adopted a dog, like
there was this feeling
of like, oh, well it's
temporary, it's this weird thing
and we all kind of
jumped in on it.
- I know Clyde, he did not sit
still for a television show.
- He did not sit, I
had him on Dana Perino,
he went and flew right
out of there. (laughing)-
- All right, fair enough.
That sounds like Clyde, yeah.
- But something about
that sort of group.
- I think there's a certain,
I didn't experience that.
And I think a certain
percent of the population
always experiences
stuff like that,
when their things are dangerous,
they actually get high.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- For me, I use the word
nuclear winter to describe that.
That to me felt
like nuclear winter,
it's like a pall filled over
everything, it was awful.
I hated it, hated
every second of it
and I was not alone, it was
really, it was darkness.
It was really a
darkness everywhere.
And that is not a healthy
thing for the human condition.
That's about as
bad as you can get.
And why did we do
it, is the question?
And why aren't we
measuring what we did
and why aren't we sort
of asking questions
about what we should do
differently next time.
- Right, that's what
I was gonna say,
why aren't we asking any
of those questions now?
We're not doing any of that.
- It's so strange.
- Do you have any-
- And by the way, I'm
not against lockdown.
I think a temporary lockdown
was probably what
we needed to do.
I mean, think about it.
- But here's the thing.
- But why?
- well, but you're-
- If they didn't
do it in Florida.
- Well, 'cause we didn't know,
we didn't know, but to be
fair, he was right not to,
you remember how he
made his decision?
He brought in a bunch
of Nobel laureates,
do you remember
that panel he had?
- I don't remember
it specifically-
- Oh, I watched it.
- But it doesn't surprise me.
- I watched it,
he brought in three
Nobel laureates
and two other guys,
if I remember right.
And he just queried them
for a couple of hours
about what this looks
like, what the data is,
how this works and he
went, at the end he went,
"I see no compelling reason,
based on what you're saying,
that we should lock down,"
and they all went, "Yeah."
- Wait, so why are
you partly for them?
- Because it was confusing
and I'm okay with people
sort of, I remember being
at the time thinking,
I was not against
locking down the schools,
that always seemed insane to me.
I also was very disturbed
that they never
were honest with us,
about who was really
at risk for this thing.
85 plus is really at risk for
these thing, kids not at risk.
And that should have been
clear from the beginning,
but the fact that we didn't
really know what was going on.
And I thought, at the
time I thought to myself,
what if I was in this position?
And I was charged with
keeping everybody safe,
I probably would prepare
for the worst case scenario,
at least for a
couple of minutes.
And I thought, I don't
think he's right, but okay,
I'll go along with it
for a little while,
never dreaming it
would go on for ever.
- Right, well, that's why if I
had that time machine, to me,
you basically do nothing.
- Oh, if I had the time machine?
- You basically do nothing, not-
- Yeah, if you had
the time machine.
- Oh, if I knew everything
I know now.
- So now it's February 2020.
- Oh, I know
everything, I know now.
- It's coming, we know
something's coming.
- I would advocate
for distancing,
I would keep kids in school.
I would, again, we
didn't know the speed
at which that
R-naught was gonna go.
'Cause we were, we would have
had, if we'd done nothing,
we would have ended
up with something
like we had in December and
January of 2020, 2021 rather.
And that was pretty nasty,
that was pretty nasty,
but we ended up with it
anyways is the point.
And the virus does
what the virus does,
there does not seem
to be a lot that we do
that really changes the
behavior of the virus.
What we can change
is how it affects us,
that we can change,
make milder illness,
get antivirals, vaccinate,
that we can do, yeah.
- Should we be paying attention
to any of these other
horse de-wormers,
or things that crazy
right-wing maniacs,
like Joe Rogan
are talking about?
- Early treatments like, can
you say the words on here,
I got put into
YouTube jail twice.
- We're on Rumble now,
we'll be all right.
- Okay, good. So I don't
think, I talked to,
there are nodes in
this pandemic for me,
in terms of the ability
to be open and honest.
One node was when Fauci said,
"Yeah, maybe this, we'll
look into whether this thing
came from a Wuhan lab."
I felt like, "Oh, now we
can have this conversation."
I was talking to a
pulmonologist yesterday
from the Cleveland Clinic
and it was on a stream show.
And he said, "Boy, at the
beginning, if you remember,
at the beginning
of the pandemic,
we all were prescribing
hydroxychloroquine.
And I thought, "Oh,
we can say that now?"
- [Dave] Right?
- Doctor's everywhere-
- Right we were getting kicked
off YouTube six months later,
for saying that.
- You couldn't say the word,
these are words,
this is a medicine that
Joy Behar and other people,
and Don Lemon had just
learned how to pronounce.
They just learned
how to pronounce it.
I've been using it for decades,
it's one of the safest
medicines you can use.
And we were prescribing it,
because we have
nothing else to offer
and this looked like
it might be helpful,
so doctors routinely
were prescribing it.
Now we can say that, we
can be honest about that.
That's what we're doing.
Didn't do much, if anything,
I think ivermectin maybe a
little better, but not much.
I think once you
have real treatments,
that's gonna all go away
and you're gonna
have real treatments
that have real effects.
It's the difference
between essentially
drinking cranberry juice
for urinary tract infection
versus taking Septra,
or taking Cipro, it's a lot
different, it's a lot different.
- Right, you mentioned
that one of the things
that's changed you in this
is that you value freedom more,
or you understand the
concept a little bit more.
The fact that you just said,
"All right, we couldn't
talk about HCQ.
- Yeah, isn't that crazy?
- And YouTube
was booting people off.
- Yup.
- And Twitter was
getting rid of people.
- For doctor's talking about,
just discussing the evidence,
not saying you should do
this or shouldn't do it,
just discussing the evidence-
- Quite literally,
quite literally,
doctors that we know, yeah.
- One hundred percent.
- Yeah, how has any of
this changed your feelings
on any of the big tech stuff?
I know that's not
totally your domain,
but as someone that communicates
this stuff for a living,
I have no doubt that
not only online options
have probably
closed in some ways,
but I would guess some of
the mainstream stuff, right?
Like, are you
getting less calls,
because you're willing to
talk about some of this stuff?
- I was getting less
calls for awhile,
now that sort of, like I said,
there are nodes in this thing
where you can start to
be honest about this
and you don't have
to cancel people
if they're trying to be honest.
So I am getting
more opportunities
to speak right now,
because people wanna
take a look at this
and see what happened,
what people's opinions are,
rather than opinions
being dangerous
and needing to be canceled,
which was, think about
how crazy that is.
Have you ever been through
a period of history
like this anywhere?
- I've personally been
through it, but. (laughs)
- Where, but how?
- (laughs) No, no, no,
well you mean just generally
about cancel culture,
this sort of thing?
- I mean, no,
I mean a period of history-
- In America we've never
had anything like this.
- Right, we've seen
anything like this.
Although we have had periods
of extreme polarization,
right, extreme.
- Oh, no,
I guess in the fifties,
some degree of like communist-
- Well, this is the
same thing, right,
this is very similar to that.
But, usually in the face
of that kind of stuff,
we come up with a
center, we really do,
whether it's Teddy Roosevelt
or Abraham Lincoln,
or these are people tell
me that Abraham Lincoln
was a radical, no,
he was a centrist.
He was interested in
finding a middle path.
I feel like we're gonna come
up with something like that,
I hope and the reality is
that's gonna be the
Populist Movement.
Trump is not the
Populist Movement,
there's gonna be some
middle much like,
Teddy Roosevelt's in
my head as the model
and something like that's
gonna kind of rise up, I think,
because there's so many
people in this country
that are just are fearful and
afraid to speak their mind
and are rational
people with good ideas
and wondering what went wrong
with their government, right.
- Well, to that point,
do you think there's
something else going on
with all of us
psychologically, that has led-
- Well, there is
something interesting.
- To this political thing?
- All right, so.
- Putting aside
COVID specifically.
- All right, see this is, okay,
I'm gonna have to build
this case for you.
- All right.
- I wrote a book on
narcissism, right?
And the book documented
very clearly,
we've had a narcissistic
turn, we have,
no disputing that anymore,
we've had, in the 1850,
they debated whether
narcissistic disorder
even existed,
there's no debate in 2021.
- (laughs) It exists-
and I, in the eighties,
I was working at a
psychiatric hospital
and we'd have these
admitting sheets
with the Axis 1,
2, and 3 diagnoses
and Axis 2 are the
personality disorders.
When I arrived there in 1985,
Axis 2 had all kinds of
different personality disorders,
obsessive compulsive,
dependent, all kinds of things,
antisocial and then
around 1988-89,
I noticed that all of a sudden,
all the other personality
disorders went away
and all the only Cluster
Bs were being admitted,
which are the narcissistic
disorders, borderline sociopath,
narcissist, histrionic.
Those were the Cluster Bs
and that's it ever since,
everyone has a
Cluster B disorder.
Now, where do the
Cluster Bs come from?
They come from childhood trauma.
Now at the same time
I was doing Loveline
and all it was every
night, every call,
sexual abuse, physical
abuse, neglect.
I mean, it was pandemic, the
seventies unleashed something
and it unleashed it
on people to do it.
First it took the attitude that
children were little beings,
little adults,
little sexual beings,
they just need to express it.
And if some adult predator
was around, it's like,
"Hey man, he's into
it, he wanted to."
There was a lot of horrible
stuff going on for a year
and that person
didn't do that once,
they did it many, many times.
And then that child
has a probability
of being a perpetrator,
so it was expanding
rapidly all over the place.
I was hearing about
it all the time.
When I wrote the
narcissist book,
I wanted to do a chapter on,
we're back to the
French Revolution again,
on pre-revolutionary France.
And the reason was,
I was looking across
the historical sweep
and I thought this
is not normal.
It's not as though
periods of this degree
of childhood sexual abuse
is normative in social,
even in highly
distressed populations,
in war and in impoverished area,
not this kind of
exploitation of children.
There are other
periods of history
where this must have happened
and the only really good one
I could find was 1750 France,
where children were
routinely marginalized,
were abused sexually,
families were broken apart.
There was libertinism everywhere
and it was destructive
to children
and then you get the
French Revolution.
I was talking to the woman
that helped me wrote
the book on narcissism.
And I said, "Do you remember
me obsessing about 1750 France
and wanting to put that in?"
And she was like, "Oh yeah,
you were hell bent on it,
but the publisher
wouldn't let me,
saying it was too far-fetched.
And the point I
wanted to make was,
is that when there's that
kind of childhood trauma,
you get a lot of narcissism
and a lot of
unregulated emotions,
particularly aggression,
and that results
in collective mobs
and guillotines, scapegoating.
Scapegoating mechanisms
is what keeps people
that are aggressive from
acting out in each other,
they get together and
they act out on one.
I didn't know
about social media.
I didn't know about
cancellation, but there it is,
that's the cancel culture.
So there's the big sweep,
but there's a new wrinkle in
this that I did not see coming.
Can I finish it?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, of course.
- And a couple of years
ago I was sitting here
and I was hearing discourse
that to me sounded delusional
and like, frankly
delusional and I thought,
"Oh my God, if somebody
came into my office in 2015
and said, 'There's Nazis, I
have to go kill some Nazis,
there's Nazis, there's a
Nazi and a Nazi and a Nazi
and she's a Nazi,' and
"Oh, well the government,
there's Russian operatives
in the White House.'"
I'd say, "You're going to
the hospital right now.
I'm gonna admit you
for delusional,"
some psychotic
disorder and I thought,
"Oh my God, that is everywhere."
We are prone to delusionality.
Well, when are people
prone to delusions?
When they become histrionic.
So we've shifted
from pure narcissism
into histrionic disorder
and histrionics are prone
to getting swept into
sort of collective ideas.
They have a lot of emotionality.
They have extreme
acting out behaviors.
I mean, it's all with us
now, it's what we're seeing.
I don't know if the
pandemic caused it,
or it was something
that's coming anyway,
but histrionic is
sort of the disorder,
the order of the day.
- All right, so now I think
we're into the meat here.
So when I turn on,
I don't have a,
I don't have cable anymore, but
when I see clips, let's say,
of MSNBC during the day,
and they are saying the most
outrageous, over the top,
white supremacists
have taken over.
Trump is leading
the Nazis for the,
like stuff that
to my ears sounds,
you live in an
alternate reality.
And I talked about
it on the show a lot,
these people live in a
different reality than me,
I don't know how
we mitigate that.
- Bring it together.
- I don't know how we do that.
So if someone is watching this
and they have someone
in their family
that is listening to this stuff
and really believes Nazis are
everywhere and all this stuff,
what would you do?
How do we de-program
these people?
- Well, I have been
obsessing about this
for a few weeks now,
as I've sort of
crystallized these ideas.
And the only way I
know of to do it,
is what we call sort
of reality testing,
getting people back to reality,
keep emphasizing real
numbers, real facts,
just keep them in reality.
It's about all you can do
and use reality testing.
- These ain't easy these days,
'cause people don't
trust numbers anymore.
- It's not easy, I know, I
know, I don't trust them either
and so that's why it's hard,
but you've got to just
stay with what's real.
Do you know any Nazis?
Have you seen Nazis?
Or like try to stay in
the reality of the moment
and the more you get to reality,
the more you can break
down the delusions.
And it's not easy and it
may not even be possible.
That's what worries me.
I don't know that it's possible.
I do know that the media, you
know this as well as I do,
the people producing the media
are really just,
they do something
and they look at the numbers,
did that create numbers or not.
Hey, when she
talked about Nazis,
it really got a spike in the
numbers, do more of that.
I don't know if they believe
what they're saying or not.
The problem is they're
fueling delusionality.
And so you have to, again,
let's talk about what
they're doing on TV here.
Let's talk about the people,
let's look at who's
creating the information
you're looking at.
Let's look at some
alternative ideas here.
You've got to stay, much
like with vaccine hesitancy,
you have to treat
people with respect
and be very sort of
magnanimous in your approach.
You have to be
just sort of, hmm.
I recommend the
use of therapeutic
wonderment all the time.
I wonder what the, if the
world were flat, I wonder.
Hmm, I wonder how that would
work with trigonometry.
Then I wonder how
they could get,
you know something like that.
Just a lot of wondering,
wondering, wondering,
and just keep the
reality coming in
and eventually you
kind of get through.
- Do you think some of
this is just sort of like,
it's almost like at the end
of a successful society.
- No, don't talk that way.
- Well, no, I still have hope,
believe me, I have
a lot of hope.
I think we can get
to some of the things
that you're talking about, I do.
I don't know that it exactly
comes out of the center,
but putting that aside,
that at some stage of
a liberal democracy
that is flourishing,
you will have allowed
in so many crazy ideas.
You will have gotten
so fat on freedom
and doing what you want
and living as you wish,
which is mostly good.
But then you will have
drag queen story hour.
You will have the surgeon
general saying that
a biological man is a female.
You will have all of this stuff.
Like it's just the end
game in a way of this,
which as a California liberal,
I think is how you
describe yourself,
is a sad position
to have to defend.
- This is again, back just
keeping reality coming in.
Reality, eventually
comes to bear.
Reality has a way of coming
in and you can say all the,
Abraham Lincoln has a famous,
some of this must've been
going on in the Civil War too,
because Abraham Lincoln has a
very, it wasn't a famous quote
it's a quote that
caught my attention,
as it pertains to
our current moment.
He came into the
cabinet meeting one day
and he, Chase and all
those guys were there
and he goes, "Gentlemen, if
I say an elephant's trunk
is a leg," hear this?
- [Dave] Yeah.
- "How many legs does
that elephant have?"
And they all go,
"Oh five, I guess."
And he goes, "No four,
calling it a leg,
doesn't make it a leg."
And I thought,
that's this moment,
you can say anything you
want it doesn't make it so,
you're trying to make it so,
it won't be, it just isn't,
you can't make things so.
But there is another
interesting thing
you said here too, also,
which is you talked about
the limits of freedom
at the same time as we're
sort of defending freedom.
I had not really
thought about that,
because in a way,
the way we got here
is because of sort
of, in a weird way,
excessive freedom to the point
that reality was subjugated.
- Well, it's more freedom to,
instead of freedom from, right?
So you want freedom
from persecution.
- Well, it reminds you of
you, right, it reminds you
of the tolerance
and intolerance,
it's intolerance in
the name of tolerance.
It's a weird, this
is a weird spot.
I do feel though, that
the excesses of freedom
have brought us to the
place where freedom from,
yes needs to be defended.
- So, I know that the, we're
actually all bouncing around
through a lot of the
stuff that's in your
book in many ways.
- It is in the book,
but let me just say
that the book is written
by me and my daughter,
she is very woke and she
actually helped me understand
some of her point of view.
I really got to a
better understanding
of where she sees these things
and it's designed
for a 15 year old
and their parents essentially,
it's something you should
leave out on your coffee table,
if you have
middle/late teenagers,
how to navigate relationships,
it was originally about consent,
'cause back before COVID
consent was something on the
heels of the Me Too movement
was a very, very
important conversation
and adolescents were
very confused about it.
We realized as we
wrote the book,
it really is about
how to navigate
relationships, generally.
- So to that point,
so you just described
your daughter as woke,
which I think a lot of people
watching this would be like,
"Wait a minute."
- In fact, in fact,
we were on Megyn Kelly
and Megyn went, "I think
you're the first woke person
I've ever had on
this show." (laughs)
Because she launched into
her patriarchy thing.
Oh yeah and Megyn
and Megyn was great.
She was very gracious
and she pushed back
and we had a nice, that's
good, that's exactly.
And then my daughter's like,
"I shouldn't be on
these kinds of shows."
I'm like, "If you
wanna make your point,
you wanna make it
to the echo chamber?
make it to Megyn Kelly,
that's where you
should be making it,
if you wanna bring
people on board
with your point of view."
- What kind of tension
has that caused you?
- Between she and I?
- Because every single person
watching this
is going through some version
of that, myself included,
- For she and I?
and you've got someone woke
in your family.
- It actually really
improved our situation,
because I think there was a,
we were forced to really
clarify our positions
to one another, by
talking to somebody else.
And it helped me, it helped me.
And by the way,
I started admiring how
she thought about things.
You can admire people
that have ideas
that are different than yours.
I feel like for her reality
will come in a little more
and she'll adjust
this something,
but I admire what
she's thinking about
and that she's struggling
with these things
and I get it, I get it, I don't
agree with it, but I get it.
And so that's how I
would approach it.
- So without making this
about her specifically,
although if you wanna,
if you wanna, feel free.
- Well, we have no issues.
- Generally speaking, if you
were to say to a woke person,
there are biological differences
between men and women,
males and females.
- You'd have to say, look, I'm
not a biological determinism.
you'd have to find the, just
get the common ground quick.
Just go, look, I agree,
gender is a construct
and it's not about
strictly the biology,
but, and I actually
put this in the book.
This is where I was pushing
back kind of hard of the book.
I was like, I'm a physician, I
have to know the sex hormones
and what they're
doing biologically,
I have to know that.
And by the way, if I'm gonna
deal with a transgender,
they are getting very
powerful medication,
from maybe me, that are hormones
that are not being produced
because of the
chromosomal situation,
that's a medical treatment.
I need to know what I'm doing.
And that's my main, that's
actually my main thing
about a treatment of
transgender right now,
is I don't think my profession
is doing a good job.
The job should be
the right treatment,
for the right patient,
at the right moment
and we have not
figured that out.
They're all getting
everything the same
and that never is good,
that's never good enough.
- What do you think
happened, I guess,
at the psychiatric layer,
when it comes to this.
I'm guessing
you're familiar with that.
- I'm not talking
about psychiatric.
- Since you wrote this book.
- I'm just talking about, push
all that aside and just say,
somebody's gonna get
treatment, when do you do it
and who do you give it to
and who's the right
one to give it to
and how do you determine that?
None of that is just
everybody gets the treatment,
no questions asked, that's it,
that's not how you do medicine.
- Right, so then what happened,
okay, so more broadly,
what happened at
the medical layer
where Abigail Shrier wrote
this incredible book about-
- Same thing, same thing,
same thing that happened
during COVID same
thing that happened,
is my physician
freezes, they freeze
and they're afraid
to do anything,
they're afraid to say anything.
Something I didn't
know until COVID
is that so many of my
peers are employees now.
So they're fearful of
doing something out of line
for their employer, they're-
- That's interesting,
so there's less that just
have their own practice now,
because of major.
- Almost doesn't exist,
it doesn't exist.
So if you say something wrong,
the employer will fire you.
And I've talked to doctors
that have been fired
for saying something online
that didn't fit the
orthodoxy of the institution,
as well as a fear of
the cancel culture
and fear of people
coming after them
encumbering their license.
I mean, they're scared,
doctors are so easily scared.
That's how we ended up
with the opioid epidemic,
because doctors started
getting criminally prosecuted
for inadequate
treatment of pain.
They were getting
fined and going,
that's not malpractice, right,
that's criminal and civil
liability and we all froze.
We stopped prescribing
for pain patients
and sent them all to the
pain management people.
And their position was pain is
what the patient says it is.
Pain control is what
the patient says it is.
You don't even need a doctor,
just ask the patient
what they need
and set it off the counter,
a lot like Starbucks,
point out what you want.
They were doing that
in Florida at one point
and that's how you got
the opioid epidemic.
- So relating this
to the trans issue,
since it's one of
the issues of the day
and since you were talking
to your daughter who's woke,
I mean, we seem unable
to have that basic thing,
but I get it you can-
- You can have it.
- There are soft ways
to have it, but when you see it-
- Get into it, then
once you're into it,
you're gonna disagree on things.
- Sure, but when
you see the surgeon,
I don't know if you saw it,
the Surgeon General
of the United States
sending out a tweet
that Rachel Levine is our
first four star female,
blah, blah, blah.
She, I'll use her
preferred pronouns,
because I'm a nice
guy, she's not female,
but when you see the
surgeon saying that-
- I get, there's a lot of
orthodoxy around the language.
Did she say female or woman?
- Female, no female
we can blow it up.
- That's the part,
'cause that's the part,
I have trouble with the
female part, I mean,
'cause I have no problem with
calling a transgender woman,
a woman, I have no
issues with any of this.
- I agree, yeah, okay.
- But when you start saying,
you start trying to try
to adjust the biology,
it's like and then I'm
concerned, then it's like,
how do I treat this person?
How do I know what
I'm dealing with?
I mean, as a gynecologist,
should I be treating men?
As a urologist, should I pretend
that women have a prostate,
screen them for prostate
cancer, because they want me to.
- I hate to tell you
what I think most of
their answers would be.
- You've got to be kidding.
- Not really.
- No, no, no.
Listen, I am very
concerned about transphobia
and about the, I don't
want those people to,
I don't want anybody
with those people.
with any conditions
to feel marginalized
or not a part of,
I want everyone to get along,
I mean that's my thing.
And so, people wanna
use certain language,
I'll try to figure it out,
I'll try to go with it,
but I'm a biologist and
there's certain things
I just have to have in order
to do my work, that's all.
- So are you surprised
how woke the hard
sciences became,
that two plus two doesn't
always equal four.
- Yes, yes, I always thought
that would not happen.
That was shocking to me,
I still think that
will quickly come back.
That can only
happen for so long,
before science doesn't work.
- Well, how quick?
I mean, well, the
question always is then
what kind of destruction
can they create.
- Well, they will do, I know,
but they will be quietly
doing what they do,
it's just the way it is,
you can't do it otherwise.
- What else is on
your mind these days?
In this just craziness
that we seem to be in.
- It is craziness.
- 'Cause it does seem like a
mass psychological disorder
that we're all going through
and you're a Republic person
in the midst of all of this.
- Yeah and it's been very-
- And it seems, see
that's what I mean
it feels like your life
sort of led to this.
- Oh, it's been very unpleasant,
it's been terribly unpleasant,
but I feel like my job is to
really keep walking through it.
But I gotta tell you, the
only thing I would say
is I'm leaning on
philosophy a lot right now.
I think stoicism has
remarkable utility right now.
Stoicism is like a
antiviral sort of system,
for our cognitive systems.
We have lots of glitches
in our cognitive system,
it's some of what's
going on here
is that people don't
know how to reason,
don't know how to think, don't
know how to assess things
and stoicism adjust the
cognitive processes very nicely.
The other thing is I'm kind of,
I didn't know I would
ever become this way,
but I find myself being
a little bit Hegelian,
in the sense that, which he
didn't actually say this,
but there's a construct
around his thinking
is that there's a antithesis,
a thesis and antithesis,
and then a synthesis.
And I feel like we're in some
sort of antithetical movement
now that will bring good things,
I'm trying to stay positive.
That there'll be good
things that come of it.
And we'll have some sort
of synthetic function
that will get us through this.
You said something to me as
we were walking in here today,
that made me worried that that
process will not take hold.
But that tends to
be how history-
- Wait, what did I say?
What did I say, you
said you were worried
right before we started.
- Well, we were talking
about cities in this country
and our concerns about them
and what a disaster they are.
And you said, "Well,
that's the plan to prove-
- Oh, well, but I don't
know that that's counter
to the idea there, it's
just that I believe
that the intentions
of these people
related to their policies,
if you defund police and
then you increase crime
and then murder goes up
and you look at the data
and you keep doing it.
My belief is that
their intentions
are to destroy some of these
cities to prove in their minds,
that capitalism doesn't work.
Thus they can usher in
whatever it is that they wanna.
That's different,
that's sort of pure-
- I get it, that's really
antithesis antithesis.
That's and we were
talking about anarchists
when we walked in here.
We were talking about Michael
Malice and things like that,
but whenever ideology
prevails, humans suffer, okay.
We need a pragmatic party,
we need a pragmatic system.
That's based on
the human reality.
How humans work, what our
motivational systems are.
The one thing is when
you sit in the middle,
you can kind of see the
excesses on both sides.
And one of the things I keep
seeing on the progressive side
is they seem in total
denial of how humans work
or what our motivational
systems are and how humans are.
Then I don't mean just that
this historical moment,
just the, I mean,
I worked for years
with humans with all kinds of
broken motivational systems.
I know how our brain works.
I know our emotional
systems work.
I know how our interpersonal
and inter-subjective
experiences are supposed to go.
They're just in abject
denial about that.
And history is
replete with examples
of when ideology becomes
the prevailing principle,
that people get harmed
massively, massively.
- Wasn't there a guy in
Germany in the thirties
who thought he was the
biggest victim all time,
and then something bad happened.
- Look you can, I
hate that that guy's
brought up all the time
and you could bring up
all kinds of other people
throughout history, they've
done the same thing.
And it's interesting that
we're getting a little lesson
on how that can happen.
One of the things that
was shocking to me,
this is one thing that I
think Malice was saying
when he was talking
to Jordan Peterson,
or Jordan Peterson
was saying it,
was that we deputize
people during this pandemic
to be an authority
if, so anybody.
'Cause I remember I got
COVID, in my humble opinion,
by trying to get the vaccine.
At a time, so I was treating
lots of COVID patients.
I was still operating
my outpatient practice
and my hospital started
offering the vaccine.
And I went, "I gotta
get this vaccine."
So I made an appointment.
I went in and when I went in,
a 28 year old guy
started screaming at me,
where are your papers?
I mean, it was like a
border crossing scene
from a Second World War film.
And I was sort of
stunned and he started,
yelling at me and I thought
I've been a staff member
at this hospital for 35
years, you treat senior staff,
do you like this?
It was so confusing to me.
I was like, "Does it
feel good to do this?"
Yes, it does, that's
how people do that.
And so didn't have
the right papers,
I had to run all
over the hospital,
I was in many poorly
ventilated rooms.
I thought, "This is how
I'm gonna get COVID,"
three days later sick and they
wouldn't get me the vaccine
because first they had to,
even though I made the case,
I said I'm treating
COVID patients,
I'm volunteering in the ER, I
wanna help with this problem.
We have employees that
are really at higher,
really we gotta be fair
and we have to give it to
our employees first, before,
So the gardeners and everybody
else got it before me
and I got sick.
- The gardener
got it before you.
- Everybody,
everybody before me.
- That was somebody
that did not like one of
your TV shows, perhaps.
All right, so in our last
couple of minutes here,
I think we've pieced together
a decent sort of
psychological picture
of what's going on
in the United States.
- Have we?
I'm still mystified
and confused.
- Well, maybe a little bit,
but I do wanna give
the devil his due here.
Obviously, I'm much more
critical of the left.
Obviously, I can talk about
the woke stuff all day,
but when you talk about some
of the personality disorders
that are maybe
happening over there,
where they don't really
understand human nature.
- I didn't say over
there, it's all of us.
- Okay, so now that I
want you to do then,
so give me some of
that on the right.
- It's all of us.
- Is there something
maybe that I'm not seeing
that's more broadly happening
on the right or what's the-
- I see the same
excesses on both sides.
It's just that one right now
is sort of more in charge
and more sort of involved
with our everyday life.
You know what I mean?
We're having interactions,
people are yelling.
I've walked by somebody,
I ran by somebody,
when I wasn't wearing a mask,
I was out running and
the guy was like, "Ah!"
Like that's that kind of thing,
I don't see that stuff
from the right. (laughs)
I don't see the signals, but-
- Right,
so what am I not
seeing there then,
if it is, I get it, they
have more culture power now
So it feels louder now.
- I wondered that
same thing myself,
what am I not seeing that,
I would say, usually
on the right,
rigidity is more of the problem
and there's more
openness on the left
and more rigidity on the right.
And the rigidity can
go towards excess.
I've seen some of our
friends say things
where I get the same, my
butt muscles tighten up,
in a similar fashion,
like, I don't think
you really mean that.
And I don't say anything,
I don't say anything
to them either,
about their early treatments
or what they're thinking
about the virus, or vaccines,
or anything like that.
It's like, you're entitled
to your opinion, that's fine.
If you want me, talk to me,
I'm available, kind of thing.
- Right, I guess for me, the
fundamental difference would be
that for whatever
rigidity is there.
And of course it is, if you're
more conservative by nature,
you're less in to change, okay.
But to me, it's like in
a time when the world
is just spinning off the cliff
because of this craziness-
- But it makes them more rigid.
- A little rigidity's okay,
and it makes them
more rigid, yeah.
- No, I agree a little
rigidity is, I'm up for it,
but the virginity can
have a problem too.
And I think that in
there creates some
of the funny thinking
and there's a, what is it
over there that bothers me,
that could get out of
control, it might, my fear is-
- I try to find it,
I'm trying to find it.
- Yeah, yeah, we should
keep an eye out for it.
- That's why I'm
asking the question.
- Because, you know why,
everyone's in hiding right now.
So we really, I
see glimpses of it.
It pops out at parties
and things where somebody,
where everyone just
goes, okay. (laughs)
And I'm thinking, where does
that go when it gets to be,
I think my fear is
there'll be retribution
and guillotines on that
side too, that's my fear.
So if the right can not do that
and stay focused on
some pragmatic solutions
and staying positive and
getting everybody on the ship,
it will be much to
everyone's advantage.
The problem is the pendulum
seems to go both ways
and I'm fearful that,
and the same processes are
going on there that elsewhere,
it's just different
themes, different themes.
It's very concerning, I'm
very worried about it,
but I remain optimistic
and that's just me,
I'm always optimistic about
people, I love people.
And I feel like
especially Americans,
my big push would
be to try to get us
under the umbrella of
what got us all here
in the first place, why
did my ancestors come here?
Why did my family run away
from the Ukrainian
genocide, thank God.
Why did they avoid the
Bolsheviks and the czarists,
all three were getting
on my family's case.
And by the way, I'm called
anti-immigrant, again, fuck you.
Because my family
escaped a genocide,
one of the ones you guys
have all forgotten about.
So they came here
because of an idea,
and we have to get clear
about that idea again,
and we have to value
that idea again,
I feel like that's what's
under attack really,
when you get right down to it,
that the principles and the
idea that those geniuses,
yes, they were old white men,
there were some slave owners,
and there were some
horrible things.
Hamilton was a screw ball,
but there was a extraordinary
set of ideas put forth
at that time that
have been the umbrella
for multiple generations of
humans, from multiple regions,
every region of the world,
and multiple ethnicities
to get along it to an uncanny
degree and lead good lives.
If we could just get
back to that, the basics,
and I'm not saying
brainwash everybody
and stand up and pledge
allegiance every day.
I'm not saying that,
just expose everybody
to those good ideas
and agree that
they're good ideas
and see if we can live
under those principles.
- Drew, I know you're a TV pro,
because not only do
you look at the camera
when you make a point.
- I do it right on the hour.
- I didn't even
have to tell you,
we can't end depressingly we
have to end positively too.
It's good to see you, my friend.
- You as well, appreciate it.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our POLITICS playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.